>> We are thrilled to welcome you to the
second annual online conference for educator.
And I recognize some of your names from
other sessions and welcome you back.
Our session, Eagle Eye Citizen;
Interactive Engagement with Civics
and Primary Sources, will be recorded.
I would like to introduce our presenters.
Kelly Schrum is Director of Educational
Projects at CHNM and associate professor
in the higher education program
and the Department of History
and Art History at George Mason University.
Schrum has worked for more than 15 years
in digital humanities, history education,
and online educational resources.
She is published widely on teaching and learning
with technology, historical thinking skills,
and the history of children
and youth in the United States.
Nate Sleeter is a PhD candidate
and a research associate at CHNM.
He teaches two online history
courses for K-12 teachers,
Hidden in Plain Sight and Virginia Studies.
These inquiry based, asynchronous courses
model how historians analyze evidence.
He also co-developed and
co-taught Teaching Hidden History,
a graduate course where students research
and create online history modules.
Sleeter has published and
presented on promoting engaged
and critical thinking in online learning.
Jessica Kilday teaches eighth grade
civics and economics in Northern Virginia.
Prior to teaching, she worked with social
studies teachers across grades four to 12.
And then associate on several
Teaching American History grants,
a professional development
program that focused on strategies
for incorporating primary sources
into classroom instruction.
Sara Collini is a PhD student in U.
S. History at George Mason University,
and a graduate research assistant at the Roy
Rosenzweig Center for History and New Media.
Collini works on educational
projects, including Eagle Eye Citizen
and a professional development website for
teachers at George Washington's Mount Vernon.
Welcome to all of you, and we're
looking forward to hearing from you.
>> We're very excited to share this
project with you, Eagle Eye Citizen.
What is an Eagle Eye Citizen?
It's a excellent question.
We're showing you a mock-up
right now of the site.
The site is in the process of being built.
We hope to get it live so
everyone can use it by the spring.
And then so, the pages you'll
be seeing are mock-ups.
Taking in the site, you notice at the
bottom there we've got big action buttons,
Solve, Create.
These are for the challenges
that will be a part of this site.
These challenges will use the enrich and
engaging Library of Congress sources.
And the third action button there is Teach.
You'll be able to use these --
these challenges -- solve --
solve and create challenges to support
teaching of civics and also history.
These challenges are interactives.
They're not games, but we're looking
to make use of the ideas in gaming.
The techniques that work in gaming while still
emphasizing the close reading, the observation,
the reflection, the questioning of
sources, and the good civics content.
As an example of some of the
game techniques we're using,
if you look in the upper right
corner of the screen there.
We have -- you'll be able to login,
you have different badges you can earn,
different ranks where you complete
these challenges and create challenges
and you'll be able to progress through the
site and build up your status as a legislator.
We'll use that as incentive
to participate in the site.
As I mentioned, students will not only
have the ability to solve challenges,
but teachers will be able to create challenges
and students will have the opportunity
to create challenges as well.
The goal for the students
solving and creating challenges is
to learn content and skill building.
The challenges and the process for
creating them are carefully designed
to reflect the best practices and
research in teaching and learning.
They emphasize 21st Century
skills such as close reading,
critical thinking, sourcing, textualization.
It'll allow teachers opportunities
to integrate content on Congress
and civic participation across the curriculum.
Our goal is to make the site relevant to
teachers of civics, adaptable to a diverse range
of middle school, high school classroom
settings with diverse learners.
So it'll reflect national content,
technology, and skill standards.
It'll be flexible for -- to maximize
educational use in a variety of settings.
Along these lines, Eagle Eye Citizens will
include a section with specific strategies
for teachers to incorporate solving and
creating challenges into their teaching.
So with that, I'm going to transition over
to Jessica Kilday, who is a classroom teacher
and has some great things to share about how
Eagle Eye Citizen can be used in the classroom.
>> Hi, everyone.
So my name is Jessica.
As Nate said, I currently teach
eighth grade civic and economics.
Before we tell you more about all of the
content that we're building in the website,
I want to get you guys started by getting you
actively participating to give you a better idea
about how your students are going to be able
to engage with the content on this site.
So the screen that you're looking at right now,
is one of our challenge types
and it's called Time After Time.
And the purpose of this challenge is to get
students thinking about sources and looking
for clues that will allow them to notice the
chronology of events and how they unfolded.
This is a mockup of the screen
that students will see
when they are participating in the challenge.
There's going to be five sources that
they'll have the chance to review.
Notice the buttons at the bottom.
They say look closer, so students will be able
to zoom in on details for each of those sources,
and their job is going to be to drag them
into the numbered slots where you see one
through five to check which
sources are in the correct order.
So first, I'm going to show you the two
-- the sources that we're going to look at
and the challenge we're going to do together all
have to do with the Women's Suffrage Movement.
So I'm first going to walk you through two of
the sources that are earliest in the chronology.
I actually had a chance to do this with
my students at the end of last year.
So the first two sources I'm going to show
you, and I'm just going to highlight some
of the things that my students noticed when
they were looking closely at these sources
and then I'll give you a chance to look
at the last three in the chronology.
So the one that's on your screen
right now, the first source,
is from the Seneca Falls Convention.
My students first noticed the date.
That it's July 19th, 1848.
They also noticed the title at the top,
where it says The First Convention.
So these gave them clues that it was
probably something early on in the chronology
of the Women's Suffrage Movement.
And then they would have gone to
read the text in the paragraph,
talking about the meeting
wanting to discuss women's rights.
The second source that's in the chronology
is the Trial of Susan B. Anthony.
This is a title page, so there's a lot
of headings, but students have the chance
to notice, again, they noticed the date.
That it's something that happened in 1872.
And then many students also noticed that it was
a trial, so someone had done something wrong.
So they figured that it would have to be
somewhere in the middle of the chronology
because it's an action that someone's taking
and then the response by the government is
that this person was arrested and then
they noticed that there's a charge
that this person was voting illegally.
The next three sources that I'm going to show
you -- so there's letters here A, B, and C,
so I'm not going to tell
you the dates specifically.
I'm going to give you a chance to look at
the sources and see what you guys notice.
The first two that we looked at, the first
one was the Seneca Falls Convention in 1848,
and then in 1872, the Trial of Susan B. Anthony.
So we're going to give you guys -- I'm going
to scroll through a larger screen of image A,
image B, and image C and you'll have 30 second
to review what you can, so if you want to jot
down notes to help you remember what
you notice, you're welcome to do that.
And then I'm going to ask you to identify which
source you think comes third in this chronology,
after the two that we just looked at.
Okay. I'm going to proceed to source B now.
And now the last source, the source C.
And it looks like -- I don't know if
you guys can see my results or not,
but eight people selected image
C, five people selected image A,
and one person selected image
B. So source C was correct,
so those of you who selected source C -- this
is a Votes for Women postcard that was published
in 1913, and to tell you a little about
what my students noticed and thought
about when they looked at the source.
They found this one the most
challenging because as you noticed,
there's no date immediately visible.
So a lot of students relied on trying to
figure out what the purpose of the document was
and placing it in the chronological order.
Some people put it first because
they had all five sources to look at
and they thought maybe this
started the conversation
for women's rights, so they put it up front.
Others put it in the middle because they thought
it was kind of continuing the conversation
about women's rights, so they really
relied on what they thought the purpose
of the document was to put it in order.
So now we have three in our chronology
here, the Seneca Falls Convention,
the Trial of Susan B. Anthony,
and the Votes for Women postcard.
So now we have two left, sources A
and B. You've already looked at them,
so I'm not going to pull them back up
again, but I'll let you guys participate now
that you know the third source, which one do you
think comes after the Votes For Women postcard?
Source A or source B?
All right, that's a pretty even split.
Almost exactly.
Eight people selected image A.
Nine people selected image B.
and my students also had trouble with this one.
The correct answer is actually
source A. For those of you
who selected this one, it's Jeannette Rankin.
She was the first Congresswoman elected in 1916.
And students, when they looked at these
sources, they were often surprised to find
that the first Congresswoman was elected
before women first gained the right to vote.
Looking closely at the source,
many students noted the caption
that she was formerly a suffrage
worker, and so they concluded
that the Women's Rights Movement had ended;
however, since voting rights are not established
in the constitution, there were several
western states who had granted women the right
to vote before it was established nationally.
So this also provides a good point of discussion
if you're a government teacher to talk
about not only the Women's Rights Movement,
but also about the distinct responsibilities
between State and Federal governments.
That they -- that the States really have
the right to determine voting rights
that are not in the constitution.
So then, finally the last source that
completes the chronology was source B,
which was of course, the ratification of
the 19th amendment which occurred in 1920.
The screen you're looking at now is the
completed challenge, so if students got all
of the sources correct, in the right order,
the screenshot on the right
shows you what students will see.
They'll see the checkmarks in the far right-hand
corner, and they'll also have the opportunity
to go back and view the full sources
in context at the Library of Congress.
And it has the dates attached to them.
If students don't get them all
right, the smaller screenshot
on the left shows that they can keep trying.
They might have two or three
more images left to correct.
After students complete the challenge,
they can review what they missed
or see that they were successful.
They'll have the opportunity to reflect on the
sources and their experience in the challenge.
And this is where teachers can
really get information from students
on what they noticed in the documents.
These are the questions my students
answered after they completed the challenge.
So I could tell what details
they were picking up on
and which ones they weren't
-- they were missing.
So following the Library of Congress
primary source analysis questions,
students will be asked to observe what
kinds of things they noticed first,
what did they see when they looked more closely
in reviewing the sources, what else do you want
to know, and what else do -- oh, what did you
learn, and what else did you want to know?
So in this challenge, many students
questioned why women gained --
why the first woman Congress --
why the first woman was elected
to Congress before she earned the right to vote?
And this is data you'll have
access to as a teacher,
as your students are completing these questions.
So now you've been able to participate
in what one of our challenges look like.
I also want to give you kind of a broader
perspective on what content you're going to find
and what this is going to
help you do in your classroom.
If you teach civics and government where
you have included all the primary sources
in our database divided out by theme, so you can
search sources that are related to citizenship,
civil rights, the legislative branch,
elections, and the constitution.
History teachers will find it useful that
there's filters to divide primary sources
out by time period, so if they're looking to --
to teach a specific topic,
the can do so that way.
History teachers might also use it to practice
close reading skills if they're introducing how
to work with primary sources and also
review civics in historical context,
particularly if you're talking about the
founding period of American Government,
you can talk about the historical event,
but also about how our government functions.
You can also use it more generally to just
talk -- discuss primary source analysis skills
and give students a chance to practice this.
Solving the challenges, students are
going to be asked to observe, reflect,
and question on the primary
sources that they're presented with.
If students create challenges,
which that will also be an option
when you're working in the site.
Students will have to reflect on what
kind of hints and prompts would be useful
for another student who's completing a
challenge that they are creating for them.
Some ways that you can incorporate
Eagle Eye Citizen into your classroom.
Depending on the time you have and the resources
you have available, you can use the challenges
as a hook to a lesson that you're planning that
goes along with something else you already do.
So for example, the way we used Women's Suffrage
to start this off, it could stimulate inquiry
about a topic and you could just
use it to catch their attention.
You could also use it if you don't have a one
to one ratio of technology in your classroom.
You can also use it to model and
scaffold how to read a primary source.
So completing a Time After Time activity as
a class, you could go through each source
on your Promethean Board and talk
about what details students notice
and put them the correct order together.
You could also use it if you do
have a one to one technology ratio,
students can work individually or in pairs
to create challenges or solve challenges.
So one of the things that will
be good about one of the things
that they should enjoy is creating challenges.
They'll be able to see what sources we have
and figure out what sources can connect --
they can make connections
between to put in order.
So for example, they could create a Time After
Time showing the expansion of voting rights,
not just for Women's Suffrage, but by age group
or other racial and background characteristics.
And next I'm going to turn it over to Kelly,
and she's going to talk to you a little bit more
about some of the other challenges
that we have in the classroom.
So as you hear more about the kinds of content
and primary sources we have on our site,
be thinking about these different ways
that you can incorporate Eagle
Eye Citizen into your classroom.
>> This is Kelly Schrum and thanks to Jessica
for that great introduction to what happens
when you use this in the classroom.
So you've seen a Time After Time suffrage
challenge and when the site goes live,
there will be many more challenges to solve, but
part of what makes Eagle Eye Citizen unique and,
I think, especially engaging is that solving a
challenge is only one piece of the larger whole.
So once you've -- I'm sorry.
Once you've solved a number of challenges,
you and your students can then go in
and create challenges, for each other,
for classes down the hall, for
classes across the country.
You, as a teacher can go in and
create challenges for your students.
So what does this look like?
So the screen you're seeing now is what you
would see if you decided from the home page
or from within the site to create a challenge.
So the first thing you would
do is choose a challenge type.
So we're going to start with Time After Time
because we just walked you through that one.
So as Jessica said, this teaches students about
change over time and about cause and effect.
The first step is to choose a theme.
So you can see here, you would choose
from Legislative Branch, Elections,
Citizenship, Constitution, or Civil Rights.
And if you wanted to learn more about it, you
would click on this blue What's This button.
You would then select your sources.
So this example, again, is the one that
Jessica showed, but you would click here
on this plus sign to select your
third source in this particular case.
Once you do that, you can browse or
search through the primary source database
and you can narrow it down by filtering.
You can filter by topic,
by type, or by time period.
And once you do that, you can
pick a particular source and say,
I want to look a little bit
more closely at this.
I want to know more about this source.
So here on this page you can learn
the basic metadata, about the source,
and you can actually link to the source as
well if you want to see it on the Library
of Congress' site, but if you want to know
even more, we're really encouraging people
to look closer, so you would click
on this green Look Closer button,
and you'll get a larger version.
And explore the source carefully.
And this look closer idea, as we've been saying,
is really kind of essential to the whole theme
of the project and we're trying to
encourage students to look closer at Library
of Congress primary sources
in lots of different ways.
Once you've selected that particular source,
you're going to pick a hint for the source,
and that would help students who
are going through the challenge
if they need a little bit
more help thinking about how
to analyze this particular primary source.
Once you've picked all five of your sources,
you get to pick a topic for the challenge.
So the topics are connected to the
sources and you're going to pick the topic
that you think most closely works with that
particular challenge that you're creating.
Once you've picked the topic, that will help
users find the challenge when they're searching
or browsing and it provides some
contextual information at the end.
And then finally, you're going
to pick a challenge name.
And if you see this little lever right here
-- if you didn't like your three options,
you could pull the lever and
you'd get some additional options.
When you're done with all that, you
get to review your whole challenge.
So at this point, you might decide,
well I really want a different
source for my third source.
You can go back and edit and change that.
You can review it.
All of the pieces.
And then you can publish it.
And at the end, as Jessica showed, your
students are then asked to reflect.
So if a student is creating this challenge,
they're going to reflect
on the learning process.
What did you want people
solving this challenge to learn?
And the answers are saved for you, the teacher.
They will not be publicly available, but
it's a way for you to assess and connect
with your students and what they're
thinking as they're creating challenges.
And finally, when they've completed
and published their challenge
and submitted their feedback, they
get a challenge complete sign -- page.
And they've earned a certain
number of votes for participating.
And as a teacher, as I said, you can
create challenges for your students,
but once your students are familiar, they
can go in and create challenges as well.
So there are two additional
challenge types, and I'm just going
to quickly walk you through and introduce them.
The first one is called Big Picture.
So solving a Big Picture challenge
is really about looking closer.
So it's about figuring out where the
important information lives on different kinds
of primary sources and it's also
thinking about close reading certain parts
of primary sources as well as the whole.
So if you were to start by
solving a Big Picture challenge,
you would see two squares turned
over and you would hit submit.
And then you would -- oh sorry -- then
you would actually select a third square
to help uncover the meaning.
So you have to figure out where in this source
might the most important information be,
and then you're going to try to
answer the question on the right.
So in this case it asks, this poster is about?
And you would click the one you
think is the correct answer based
on the information you have.
If you get it correct, the
whole source will reveal itself.
And if it's incorrect, you
get a try again message.
Two more squares will turn over automatically
and then the person solving the challenge gets
to pick another square to
turn over and then again,
they get a second chance to answer the question.
When students complete the challenge, they
then reflect on the process, and these answers,
as we said earlier, are really designed
for you to review as an assessment tool
and to help students show
their thinking process.
So to really capture the student thinking,
but they will not be shared publicly.
They'll be specifically available for you as
the teacher who set up a class to use the site.
At the end of the challenge is a bird's eye
view and this also is context on the theme
and the topic for this particular
challenge, as well as links to other Library
of Congress resources that
are connected to this.
As you can see on the right,
students can then keep going.
So they can earn more votes by sharing,
by rating this particular challenge,
by solving another challenge,
or by creating one of their own.
And one of my favorite parts with Big Picture
is when you go in to create a challenge,
you get to pick the two squares
that are turned over at the start.
So really have to kind of think
through, well, what are the pros and cons
of picking this square verses that square.
You want to provide enough
information to entice the viewer,
but not so much that you give
away the answer at first glance.
As we've learned from working on this project
for the last year, creating challenges is a lot
of hard work, but it's also a lot
of fun and it's very engaging.
So the last challenge type
is called Sort it Out.
And this one is really about making
connections, thinking about context,
and how different sources can work together
to explore issues in civics and history.
So Sort it Out asks users to sort five sources.
You see them in a stack over here.
To sort these five sources into two categories
reflecting their historical and civic context.
So in this case we have the American
Revolution and the Civil War.
And students can look closer at each source to
examine it, to learn more, they can get a hint
to help them look closer at this particular
source, and then they're going to drag
that source into one category or the other.
If you put it in the wrong category,
it pops to the bottom of the deck
and then they have another
chance to sort it again,
after they finish the rest of the sources.
So this is what it looks like
when you've gotten them all right.
So what do you get for all this work
solving and creating challenges?
This is the profile page, and as Nate
mentioned, these are all from the mockups.
We're building the site right now
so we can't show it to you live.
But when it is live and you're logged in,
you get votes that change your rank over here
on the right, so you can move from a member of
Congress all the way up to a Master Legislator.
You can also earn votes by solving or
creating challenges on particular topics.
Here you can see your challenges,
and you earn votes also
by other people rating your
challenge and solving your challenge.
So now Sara's going to walk you
through some of the wonderful Library
of Congress primary sources
in Eagle Eye Citizen.
And there are many more to come.
And we're hoping that you'll help us with that.
So we'll talk a little bit more about
that at the end of our presentation.
>> Thank you Kelly.
So as Kelly said, we want to show you
a small sampling of the different kinds
of primary sources from the Library of Congress
that are in Eagle Eye Citizen, that students
and teachers can explore in civics and history.
So in selecting these sources, we really aimed
for ones that are engaging, and exciting,
and represent a mix of historical and
more contemporary topics and issues.
And the main primary source formats
are audio, video, text, and image.
And include sheet music, speeches, newspaper
articles, political campaign posters,
photographs, and legislation, and many more.
So the following slides, I'm going to show you
a selection of primary sources in the database
to give you an idea of the breadth
of sources available in civics
and history already in Eagle Eye Citizen.
So the first is the cover for sheet music for
a 19th Century campaign song called The Boys
in Blue Will See it Through, for Rutherford
B. Hayes and we have a modern recording
of this music to really engage
students with this type of source.
So the link to audio at the bottom of
this slide will take you to the recording.
So I think that this is a really great
source for students to learn about elections
and campaigning and how they
evolved throughout history.
So the next source format are videos, and this
is a video clip of Teddy Roosevelt campaigning
in 1912 for the Progressive party.
We can't play the clip here, but this type
of source also really excites students
about elections, the Progressive party, third
parties in general, as well as platforms
in campaigns and the role of
technology in campaigning.
There are also many text sources in
Eagle Eye, including newspaper articles.
This one in particular is from a Minnesota
newspaper discussing Jim Crow segregation
in the south and the Plessy
versus Ferguson case.
This type of source really connects
to the constitution and checks
and balances as well as civil rights.
Another more contemporary text
source is of course, legislation.
And many of these sources
come from congress.gov.
This is the first page of the
Help America Vote Act from 2002
that aims to better facilitate voting.
And this source of course, connects to
voting and election, but can also be used
in a more historical challenge about the
evolution of voting in the United States.
So moving on to images, many, many of the
primary sources in Eagle Eye Citizen are images.
And this one in particular is a photograph
of the March on Washington from 1963.
And it is very captivating, as you
can see, and really engages students,
not only in civil rights,
but also freedom of assembly,
freedom of speech, and civic participation.
So the last source example that I'm
going to show you is campaign posters,
and this one for example is of Shirley
Chisholm campaigning for president in 1972
and she was the first African-American candidate
for a major party nomination and the first woman
to run for the Democratic Party nomination.
So all of these sources shown here
are only a small sampling of the
over 100 primary sources already
in Eagle Eye Citizen, that students
and teachers can use to explore
civics and history.
So now I'm going to turn it over to
Nate to discuss how you can get involved
with this project and even
contribute more primary source ideas.
>> Thanks Sara.
Yes, well as I hope you can tell, we
are very excited about this project,
excited about Eagle Eye Citizen,
and we'd be extremely excited
for you to get involved as well.
The link on the page is to a Google Form.
If you'd like to be the first
to know [inaudible] the site goes
live, you can sign up for that.
You would love to contribute, some great
primary sources that maybe you're using
in your classroom that you've
seen being used very successfully,
we would love to know about them.
And we would love to have people to pilot
test the site before it actually goes live.
As I said, the site will be
launched sometime in the spring,
and if you want to be among the first to know
when it goes live, please fill out our form
and if you have anything you want to
share, we would love to hear from you.
That concludes our presentation and I
want to thank you all for joining us.